[Applause]
you look so beautiful same with you i
was like i have to look at the lens but
i really just want to look at you
so if i do that that's why because
you're really beautiful too
oh you're so beautiful inside and
out i was so excited to have this
conversation with you
and i did a lot of homework uh for it
because
there were so many things i wanted to
discuss with you
and you have this new series which i saw
it i i was so scared i had to text
everyone
on the show that i was like is i'm so
scared right now
please like and anyone whilst watching
it i'm terrified i need
i need people tell me your secrets it's
this buzzy new amazon show
i mean it taps into my worst nightmare
obviously um and i think every mother
parent's worst nightmare how did you
handle
the subject matter and how are you so
strong because it's incredible you know
i wasn't that interested in playing a
pure
bad sociopath person i always like to
know why people do what they do
and we started from this pretty simple
premise and a pretty universal premise
which is
how far would you go to find and protect
your child
and you know i feel like i've said it
this
and and you hear it all the time like
i'm not a violent person but if anybody
came after my kid you know so it's sort
of like this culturally
sanctioned um reason for going nuts
and so i started in a pretty place where
i could
horribly try to imagine um and then
and then i just went on this rocket ride
one of the things
with your podcast the challengers of
which you say
that you should look at things not as
roadblocks but as doorways and i was
listening
to the podcast that you talked to your
amazing husband brad silberling who's an
incredible director
and he lost his girlfriend rebecca
schaefer who was an actress
and i thought it was so incredible that
you guys
talked about that story yeah well that
that's sort of a prime example of you
know
this this devastating thing that
happened to him which is getting the
call that nobody wants to get which is
that your loved one has been
shot dead randomly um and it
reverberated throughout
la and throughout the world and it was
sort of kind of the first time that
stalker
stuff sort of really came to the fore um
i met brad about five years after that
and i immediately was drawn to him and
when i heard that
fact about him i said um you know i i
i have all these big feelings but i i
don't know what to do
with with this idea that he was like in
love with this beautiful young woman who
was shot down and if
she hadn't died you know i was kind of
hung up on like there's only one for
everybody and if she hadn't died
and i was sloppy seconds and just i was
all you know
in love i was vulnerable and my father
said um
well if if it continues and he continues
to love you in the way that that is good
for you you may come to feel grateful
to her for teaching the how to love and
that is absolutely what happened and so
my heart
you know now rebecca's in my heart in a
way that i you know wasn't like
competition it wasn't jealousy it was
like
oh all these things that happened to us
prepare us um
to to love and to be more present and
that is 100 percent true
thank you so much for a sharing that
wisdom of how we can all learn
because you cannot change someone's
history so
you know embracing and honoring is
really the only approach we have but
gosh it takes
lifetimes it feels like to learn that
and a lot of relationships
and it happened in 1989 um in west
hollywood and in 1989 i moved out into
my first apartment at 14
emancipated by the courts and
this very much was front and center news
there was no stories like it it changed
the landscape
for everyone and um i thank you for
sharing that because i was a part of
that time and that culture
um when rebecca was unfortunately killed
it it it changed everything for everyone
well i am so enamored with you
and the way that you are living your
life sharing it
and giving us all the nod that looking
at it and talking about it is
what brings the light and gets rid of
the darkness
and thank you for leading the charge on
that with your podcast the challengers
and if you want to watch this
buzzy important cool show that
everybody's talking about
and it is riveting um
it is called tell me your secrets it's
on amazon prime right now
and thank you amy oh it's my okay now
i'm going to take you in in all your
beauty and your adorableness and you
know what
that accordion potato like who needs
that
that's just like so much work and you
know
100 thank you 100 the accordion potato
gets up
and um thank you so much right back at
you thank you for being a light
in this world thank you thank you